m
[Musique]
minuit la vie commence les premiers des
quelques milliers de camions qui forment
l'armada des halles centrales à rift
avec leur chargement c'est le début d'un
gigantesque encombrement qui ne sort
donnera qu'avec le jour
l'état de légume jonchent le carreau en
attendant les enchères une animation
égale règne dans les pavillons dont le
plus actif et est sans doute le plus
spectaculaire est celui de la boucherie
puisqu'il y passe et l'avant-veille de
noël quelques 1800 tonnes de viande
[Musique]
puis à 4 heures de nouveaux visages
apparaissent et ce sont aussi des
visages des halles ceux de ces soirées
de fête qui cherche dans cette activité
nocturne un prétexte à leurs insomnies
[Musique]
avant l'aube s'anime tout le peuple des
manutentionnaires avec le diable et les
petits acheteurs des marchés
et ce sont les scènes toujours
renouvelée des marchandages et le
spectacle tantôt mouvementée temps aux
paisibles de tout un monde un nom de
travail qui se détend dans la chaleur
bienveillante du bistrot
le trou pied à ses exigences tout comme
la pipe soeurs des pauvres dans cette
course matinale à la nourriture
[Musique]
vers 9h07 autour des ménagères tandis
que pour compléter leurs maigres
ressources d'un vieillard récupère de
quoi faire une soupe
[Musique]
et désormais l'activité va se ralentir
peu un peu le mouvement décroître pour
laisser la place au service du
nettoiement afin que tout soit net à
l'heure de midi pendant douze heures de
minuit à midi les halles maintenant
déserte or on brasse et jusqu'à 30000
tonnes de marchandises dont paris se
nourrir à tout un jour
[Musique]